welcome listener you are on the plastic
pills podcast and the next minute or so
is all you'll hear from me this week at
least on the public feed before this
real kick-ass discussion between matt
victor and featuring the co-host of the
know your enemy podcast mr matthew
sitman
and just in case you're lost here the
enemy is conservatism with american
conservatism in focus for obvious
reasons this week
for the last little bit they've been
busy little bees
but this discussion is more about the
conservative intellectual tradition
which it might be a mistake to
underestimate as i think this episode
will make clear it goes it goes deeper
than the cancel culture babies on
youtube certainly
anyway i'm here uninvited inserting
myself into the conversation quite
literally
because as can happen when you have
three experts in the room talking to
each other
these guys jump right into discussing
straussian's or straussianism
without much of a precursory coverage on
what that means or who leo strauss was
so i thought that i'd do that real quick
here so that you can get as much out of
the discussion as possible
so leo strauss i got to admit i have
affection for he's a very good writer
very passionate writer and a very
passionate advocate for
close reading
particularly of political philosophers
like plato aristotle machiavelli and the
list goes on and he writes you know to
really understand these thinkers who are
not able to say everything that they
thought because of
the potential political backlash that
might await them
so to really know them you need to spend
a long time with the texts
understanding that there's
first of all what is said on the surface
but then grasping that there are
hidden meanings or some some esoteric
statements that they saved for
their true friends who are they're close
readers and that's under layers of irony
or sometimes noble lies
and and all that sounds pretty good
right so why is straussianism then
considered a legitimation of
right-wing intellectuals
so
also in strauss we find this vision of
the western tradition capital w capital
t
and
the western tradition is for strauss
this unprecedented and brilliant amalgam
of reason
and revelation
and this is often said in terms of
western civilization is athens plus
jerusalem so this is unique in history
and
for for this
group of people the success of the
western tradition is due to
this very special combo meal where greek
rationality
meets judeo-christian universality as
revealed by god of course
so you can probably see where this is
going
these days
the western tradition is under attack by
relativism or what they call historicism
and historicism is just to say that
ideas don't come from god or universal
reason that they are historically
contingent
and
almost all the time not nearly as
morally pure as they present themselves
and this is where the the acolytes
you know quit reading closely like
strauss himself advocated so he's a
convenient ally so for the straussians
western civilization is on the brink of
moral collapse
because of these historical relativists
saying that god and the truth and the
beautiful and the good
aren't aren't transcendent that they're
contingent so although none of them are
actually straussians you can hear the
echoes that connect
straussian philosophy and the straussian
method of reading to the whiny
youtubers the shapiro's peterson's
rubens all complaining about leftist
marxist relativists nihilists
and and the list goes on then these
people are all at the gates because they
they criticize western traditional
values and the spread of western
traditional values was completely based
on their merit and not because of any
material conditions or concerted efforts
to
globalize them
so in this episode
mr sitman and the guys do
a great job of showing that there's an
iceberg
of
funding and think tanks and institutions
and grooming that goes on behind the
scenes
in american conservatism even in
university departments
where this narrative of of
civilizational collapse is pushed and
the need to conserve
the western tradition
so anyway that is enough for me i just
wanted to briefly expound this
relationship between leo strauss who i
who i find to be quite an inspiring
writer i have to say
but how that trickles down into the
conservative networks more broadly and
i'm not just talking about media
personalities but the think tanks the
institutions and ultimately as we've
seen
lately public policy so that's my
preface so please
now enjoy this excellent conversation
[Music]
welcome matt sipman back to the show uh
we're really excited to have you both of
us are big know your enemy fans i also
really like uh sam adler and that's a
shame he couldn't be here also but he
wrote some really great stuff on the new
republic recently so it's a real
pleasure to have you here yeah thank you
i'm happy to be here and uh uh i'm fans
of both of yours and uh excited to be
talking with you awesome yeah and just
quickly about sam adler i will say that
sam edelbach maybe a couple months sam
adler bell yes he did he did such a
great episode on like freudian
psychoanalysis
and politics or something that was like
i think you weren't there for that one
um but yeah just a quick aside of
listeners because a lot of our listeners
are into psychoanalysis so that's a
great episode too yeah no and uh maybe
just uh to break some news here uh that
was a episode sam did with pat
blanchfield uh who's a brilliant guy and
uh you know sometimes sam and i do the
bonus episodes kind of one-on-one like a
book episode or something like that but
you know that got such a response that
we're kind of gonna do some more about
that this summer or related so we're
gonna do an episode on christopher lash
with uh chris chris lehmann um former
editor of the new republic and one of
lash's last students actually which i
didn't know until we
started talking about this and then
maybe um you know the philip reef book
trying for the therapeutic
um which is such a huge deal on the
right uh the uses of freud after faith i
think maybe later in the summer we're
going to do uh an episode about that
book with
uh some of our freudian friends
i mean yeah i mean
that'd be really interesting i mean
that's one of the things that i really
like about you guys and you have a
couple of
really but it's anyway it was like
general uh episodes like your trilogy on
abortion where you more or less cover
the whole history um
of abortion activism on the religious
right the intellectuals behind it what
happened at the supreme court uh with
the 5 4 podcast which i really enjoyed
you know as a kind of legal nerd myself
uh but then you also have these more
idiosyncratic episodes on cell bellow
and allen bloom where it's a little bit
insider baseball but you really feel
like you get to know the subject matter
a little bit so
there's a lot of great stuff there and
actually just for those of our listeners
who ha have no familiarity with you uh
or know your enemy can you tell us a
little bit about how it is that you can
be so interested about in conservatism
and you're a little bit about your own
political journey
sure uh the short version is that um
i mean know your enemy is is a podcast
as i mentioned i do with my great friend
sam other bell um we started it i think
uh spring of 2019 so
it's actually we've been doing it for a
few years now um
but it's focused on the right on the
conservative movement in the united
states mostly the post-war you know um
uh movement that the conservative
intellectual movement that we associate
with you know the rise of ronald reagan
and kind of the the rightward shift in
our politics uh but i my interest in
that stem from the fact that i was a
young conservative uh i'm on the left
now i don't hesitate to call myself a
socialist a democratic socialist i'm i'm
on descent's editorial board now
yeah um and i i should say the descent
tradition is really the one i feel most
comfortable identifying with uh some of
the emphases they've had over the years
so i'm very proud of that
um and one reason i became connected to
dissent was as a young conservative when
my when i was 23 years old i think the i
took a graduate seminar with michael
kazan uh in the history department at
georgetown and kind of
uh it was on the american conservative
movement actually and he this was like
you know uh
spring of 2005 after george w bush had
won reelection and it was really like a
maybe there's something we're missing
here uh you know why do they keep
winning and he said that at the start of
the class that's partly why he was drawn
to those figures and those questions but
i was a young conservative i grew up in
central pennsylvania
both religiously and politically
conservative i was raised in
a fundamentalist baptist church um
fundamentalist is not my pejorative it's
it's their self-descriptor um king james
bible a lot of end times stuff uh and
again right in central pennsylvania
which became like the heart of trump
country in my state uh the county i grew
up in when i think 71 percent for donald
trump in the 2020 election to give you a
sense of things
um and i went to a conservative
evangelical christian college grove city
college um and uh so you know
uh and then even my first few years of
graduate school i was definitely uh
still involved in the conservative
movement they actually take really great
care of
uh graduate student phd student types
who they see some potential in so
you know i'm not an embittered x
conservative uh i mean we can talk about
some of why i moved uh you know left
over time
i never liked to truncate my conversion
story
too much to make it seem like it was a
saw on the road to damascus or you know
a bright light older call kind of thing
where it changed in a moment it
literally was more gradual you read
irving howe and then all of a sudden
things were made there right
yeah right right it wasn't like that but
you know into my 20s i was still in kind
of the more intellectual academically
oriented wing of of
conservatism if you can call it that
which i think was really the best wing
of it um i think it probably kept me
it made me feel like i didn't have to
entirely sort of abandon the right in
some way longer than it might have
otherwise because
of you know there were some really
wonderful people who who were very kind
to me and who i learned a lot from and
were very generous to me and um
uh uh but it really was kind of by the
end of graduate school you know kind of
end of my 20s
i never finished my phd uh i permit abd
so i don't want to claim any scholarly
expertise here that i don't have but
um you know by the time i was in my
early 30s i was you know definitely not
a conservative anymore uh late 20s early
30s do you think
go ahead do you think do you think your
political shift um had anything to do
with you not bothering to finish your
phd or were those things kind of just
unrelated it's a good reason not to
finish if you go tell your supervisors
like look i've completely changed my
audiological frameworks well it depends
what the topic was no no uh i can talk
about the topic a bit but you know
i would say the thing that actually
connects those two and i've written
about this and sam and i did an episode
on it was my experience of depression
um
i reviewed i had a long kind of essay
review of george shilaba's really
wonderful book how to be depressed
and i talk about the relationship
between depression and my political
views which is sort of just like a it
was a
experience of something that i could not
will myself out of right
uh and so
i think it was sort of the nail in the
coffin to sort of a bootstrapping myth
of meritocracy you know people's
problems are ultimately their own uh you
have their own doing
a sort of personal responsibility
rhetoric uh i you know both practically
it meant i had trouble writing the
dissertation and you know being
productive in the way i needed to uh
but it also factored into my political
views as i said you know it's kind of uh
and i think it's one of the distinctive
ways i think about being on the left
which is not a promethean perfectability
utopianism but actually a profound
awareness of you know how flawed and
fallible we are and how we all struggle
with things that again are not problems
of our own making or choosing
so um that's how i would say my the
different parts of my life connected
there uh the academic and the political
uh and my my
my focus was on early modern political
thought
uh the reformation kind of political
thought and theology in that period so
it wasn't really um
it would not wouldn't have been bound up
in any ideological transformations but i
can say this is
i was starting to lose confidence in the
project in another sense because i'm
catholic now too
um which had been a long time coming uh
uh i mean i was at georgetown in the you
know in my 20s
uh drinking gin and cocktails with the
jesuit priests you know at the jezrez
overlooking the potomac i remember
father fields especially you know really
you know drilling me theologically uh
giving me a hard time not a hard time a
playful hard time you know uh of
intrachristian uh debate and discourse
uh but you know i was writing a lot
about calvin
uh and because i thought calvin was an
important part of you know the kind of
mix of things that then you would see
and say hobbs rousseau even uh rousseau
has the great footnote that those who
read calvin only as a theologian fail to
understand him or something like that i
think it's a footnote in the social
contract
um
so
you know i think i did want
my reading of calvin to be true which
was kind of like what if marilyn
robinson did political theory
that that was how i was kind of trying
to read calvin from the perspective of
political theorist
slightly you know more generous toward
him thinking he you know uh not locating
all the ills of the modern world you
know in the reformation or something or
nominalism whatever it might be um
but yeah so i think actually
uh
the third and final transformation i
made which was from protestant to
catholic uh actually had the most
bearing in some ways on my
uh how i came to think of the
intellectual project that i never
finished as a graduate student
well i'd like to ask a question that we
don't normally get to ask on this
podcast
because
you've been very overt about the kind of
spiritual dimensions both to your own
emotional journey and your ideological
journey and i was wondering if you can
tell us a little bit about that like has
your relationship with god changed or
your understanding of god changed
alongside your politics and i'm saying
this from personal experience right i
kind of started off as a pretty
conservative roman catholic you know
growing up in small town ontario you
know then i gradually lost my faith at
18 you read a lot of niche and camo and
all the typical stuff thinking you know
no one understands me and you know now i
work for a group called the super
christian socialism and i've kind of
reformulated a lot of my earlier views
to be more in line with the way i look
at things now but it's was quite a
journey and it'd be hard for me to
disconnect you know my kind of spiritual
orientation from my politics and i'm
just wondering if the same is true for
you
yeah no that's a really good question
and um
maybe i should clarify by saying that i
mean my religion and my politics are
linked but i wouldn't want to say that
like
a change in one caused the change in the
other they've they kind of evolved in
tandem almost on two different tracks
and they were mutually reinforcing uh i
mean obviously there are uh resources in
the catholic tradition that i think
um i mean are exemplified right now by
say pope francis's encyclical ladato see
you know um the the catholic tradition
of
um
you know being pro-union pro-worker you
know this the the documents that you
know are are you know pretty solid on on
a lot of those things uh maybe not the
way i'd exactly formulate them but you
know like it's i think in the past few
years we've seen even like the kind of
catholic fondness for bernie younger
catholics on the left right that was a
thing and
in some ways it's more of a natural fit
than than you might guess but i do feel
like there's that aspect of the catholic
tradition has been
more and more noticed at the level of
like public discourse than it might have
been for quite a while you might have to
go back to like dorothy day or and
thomas merton and the bergen brothers or
something to you know i think have a
similar
moment of flourishing of a more radical
left-leaning catholicism um
but i would you know the way i would
answer your question is that
i for whatever reason
i hate to put it this way but it's easy
for me to believe in god in some sense i
have a instinctive
hunger for
those things i'm a very spiritual person
i've had yeah
however you'd want to phrase it you know
that part of it is i feel that talk very
persistently and even in the depths of
my worst depression that didn't really
leave me
um you know sometimes you might think is
this god a loving god or not
you know uh but but the basic kind of
existence of god was not something that
that i
that's like the looming question for me
it's more like i have these instincts
and impulses i've had genuine mystical
religious experiences in my life and
i've tried to figure out what to do with
them and for me you know there's a lot
of reasons i became catholic but i think
it was
you know when you grow up fundamentalist
it's a very like
world denying
body denying experience
well religious experiences is fine but
you know it's it's
it's a a bit um
mana keen and a bit um disembodied
sometimes and so for me i i as i got got
older and grew up i found like
the life is hard and difficult but there
were moments of great beauty and
transcendence or fullness you know
sometimes even a very simple things and
i've sometimes have said you know c.s
lewis wrote the book the problem of pain
i wanted to write the problem of
pleasure
you know like does does the existence of
beautiful
wonderful
things and moments in our life tell us
anything about the character of reality
or you know uh god's existence or not or
or what kind of god
that god is you know um that to me was a
big question so
catholicism to borrow a line of walker
percy's there's a lot of catholic stuff
you know
um holy water rosaries statues um
you you kneel and your hands are on the
you know
old wood pew in front of you and you
know it's um
it's a
faith of
sensuality in some ways in that way you
know our
it's a not a faith that kind of goes
runs away from our bodies and embodied
existence but goes into it and of course
the the culmination of that is the the
eucharist where we think jesus is
literally present in the bread and the
wine uh however you want to render that
formulation but it's it's real and so uh
that was why i was tugged toward
catholicism and you know along the way
there were a lot of you know how i
understood the bible obviously you know
if you grow up fundamentalist you just
and you learn anything about the history
of christianity and
uh you know how how uh the bible came to
be
compiled
um and put together and
just those kinds of things you you know
i
led me in a catholic direction too but
um
you know uh that's that's i think the
short version of of how i ended up uh
where i am
yeah that's so intriguing you know i
i'll say listening to all this as
someone who grew up with even though my
parents are from chile so you'd expect
you know some sort of catholicism but i
would just for whatever reason
you know uh unlikely reason both my
parents were like pretty much atheists
like you know totally secular households
so you know listening to this stuff it's
you know um not not it's it doesn't make
like a natural intuitive connection but
i think what you've said about um the
catholicism and like the the presence of
beauty and pleasure seems really
compelling because my only sort of like
outsider engagement with like thinking
about okay which type of christianity
makes sense was i don't know if you've
read like umberto echoes book like the
uh you know the one about what's it
called the
no the one of it with the library
sorry
the name of the rose yeah the name of
the rose no you haven't okay because
there there's that whole i guess it was
like the debate between the franciscans
and like the you know um
you know i don't remember the two it's
been a while and i remember thinking to
myself oh of course like all this
ornamentality of catholicism you know it
seems like it would be like counter to
this like true teaching as obviously
like a total like non-believer but then
i think what you just said about sort of
like the body not denying it um it's
just it's compelling and it's like
another side of an argument that i
hadn't heard so yeah that's interesting
and i would say even if you go back and
look at like the augustinian tradition
uh one of the interesting things that
comes through
in confessions uh i think most clearly
this you know my reading is inspired by
like somebody like obery hendricks right
is the fact that he does actually
chastise the manikins and other people
for
demeaning the body uh or suggesting that
the body is the source of sin because of
course the real source of sin is the
spirit which misuses the body uh
the body you know itself is a gift from
god and we need to appreciate it as such
so i do think that there's a lot of gas
left in that tank uh when it comes to
trying to reformulate something like
catholicism or christianity for the 21st
century uh but you know that's not what
we're here to talk about sadly so right
and it's a good segment to talk a little
bit about some of the things that victor
and i have chatted about before uh which
is these new kinds of
conservatism that are emerging uh in the
united states and elsewhere many of
which are deeply inspired by militantly
right-wing forms uh of catholicism uh so
you can think about the post-liberals as
being you know exemplars there are
people like adrian vimulay uh
patrick dineen uh sorba mari who's a
convert uh all these people have really
risen in profile over the last couple of
years could you tell us a little bit
about
how we got there uh what's the also also
interesting sorry sorry to cut you off
but i'm also you know worth noting too
that you know uh the the the supreme
court is also like a bunch of catholics
isn't it like the ones you at least
except for i think sotomayor maybe but
uh pretty much all the conservatives are
catholic is that right
gorsuch was baptized catholic uh but as
an adult i think has attended an
episcopal church
so
when you uh get in these arguments it's
always like well do you account course
that you're not but it's beside the
point because like five yeah or maybe
six you know uh on the right are
catholic right and uh um
yeah it's a notable presence
anyway sorry no no no no yeah i was
almost i was pretty much done right and
i should say it's also interesting that
um gorsuch was john finishes uh student
and
fitness is arguably the most important
to mystic legal and political philosophy
i'd even say in the world right now um
and you can definitely see the influence
of a lot of us thinking on some of these
post-liberal characters but you know
we'll talk a little bit about what the
substance of their thought is maybe
later on but given your background and
the kind of history of this movement
both intellectually and practically uh
can you tell us a little bit about how
we transition to this post-liberal
moment uh was it a long time coming was
it inevitable was it contingent what led
us here
well it's a it's an interesting question
in part because
um
i mean you mentioned john finis uh in
the
the the third and final episode sam and
i didn't know your enemy about roe we we
talked about
you know we we didn't want to make it a
totally intellectual ideas driven story
so a lot of the other two episodes are
about
you know other aspects of the
anti-abortion movement the anti-choice
movement but
um
finis you know was the teacher of robbie
george uh the princeton professor and uh
uh founder of the james madison society
or james madison program at princeton
which is
i think one of the first and
far and away the most effective of these
kind of conservative beachheads at
universities where they can bring in
conservative scholars for like a
visiting year and they might teach a
class they might you know get a chance
to work on a book that kind of thing so
the finnis influence
he was gorsuch's teacher he was robbie
george's teacher but then also if you
kind of look at the net the slightly
younger generation people more my age uh
our age i'm guessing roughly uh who are
now coming to leadership positions in
the conservative movement uh it's robbie
george's student um
anderson what's his uh first name um
ryan anderson sorry ryan anderson a
robbie george student
who then went on to do he was an
undergrad
bobby george was his undergrad mentor
and then he went on to do a phd in
political theory at notre dame uh ryan
anderson he's the current president of
the ethics and public policy center um
uh you know it's it's the
the tracing and charting of these
influences is really interesting um but
among some of the other figures you
mentioned um when i was a young
conservative uh you know and in graduate
school patrick jeanine was on my
dissertation committee really yeah wow
you knew him quite well um we were very
close um i mean he came together he's a
smart guy i will say i mean um there's a
reason coronel west had nice things to
say about why liberalism failed and even
didn't obama you know uh yeah he was on
his summer reading yeah he wrote here
yeah yeah so someone like deneen was on
my uh again dissertation committee the
dissertation i didn't write but i like
we were close enough he he brought his
son to spend a weekend with me and my
family in central pennsylvania uh to
teach him how to shoot guns he'd never
really shot before and
my dad that's interesting my dad makes
custom rifles for a living uh crazy
thing to say these days it's more for
like competitive target shooters or big
game hunters uh he doesn't sell anything
uh
of the sort we've seen lately in the
news i'll put it that way
uh but um josh mitchell who's one of the
signees of the new national conservatism
manifesto or statement of principles
they put out just a few few days ago he
was uh my my main uh mentor the the
chair of my committee
um so those are two people active in the
national conservatism stuff i mean the
you know the the actual conferences that
yarmazzoni and others put on right um
and my third reader
uh was
jean bethka elstein
who
was
you know a very prominent proponent of
the iraq war debated stanley haross in
the pages of first things around that
time uh and and then two i got to know a
fair number of straussians uh jim caesar
at the university of virginia harvey
mansfield
uh who just turned 90 i guess um
celebrated
yeah um i i
hadley arkis a very important
anti-abortion figure political theorist
at amherst i knew a lot of these people
and i can say uh
the
i don't i'm still trying to figure out
what exactly happened
because i one thing i've tried to say in
different ways i know your enemy
uh
is that there's a lot of continuities of
course like you go back to the origins
of the conservative movement and you say
okay an orange a movement that sort of
was hatched to oppose or that you know
really gained steam to oppose the civil
rights movement um was you know in bed
with the birchers and and conspiratorial
anti-communism um
anti-democratic in that sense you know
uh that the white rates should rule in
the south even if they didn't have a
numeric
majority as bill buckley put it in the
infamous 1957 national review editorial
why the south must prevail like it's not
shocking that it cashes out in something
like trump or you know the the the kind
of more nationalist uh maybe
authoritarian uh more anti-democratic
strains that are you know seem to have
come to the fore they've always been
there but i can't say i just didn't hear
people talking
the way i see and hear and read you know
conservative these post liberal or you
know new right
uh figures talking today um
and i think part of it is
you know what intervened between
my
early 20s and and
my mid-30s while a black president for
one thing
um i think especially for the religious
ones the catholics the combination of
trump coming onto the scene and francis
becoming pope was like this this kind of
combination that broke their brains
because they couldn't even kind of have
the security of a church that they knew
was
their reliable ally uh politically and
otherwise and it really is true that the
conservative movement in the united
states um
under uh john paul ii
and bennett the 16th
was extremely close with uh the vatican
you know father newhouse the the founder
of first things you know was
you know on ewtn all the time i mean
george why are listeners who don't know
first things is
arguably uh the premier uh
kind of right christian intellectual
magazine uh in the united states um
you know there's some people who claim
uh you know that it's not anymore you
know sir mary might have something to
say about that but you know it's
the place where you go if you want
advanced intellectual arguments
presented in
a publicly readable and digestible way
yeah it was definitely the most serious
um especially in its heyday i think the
most serious um intellectual magazine of
the religious right and religious
concern conservatism
but george weigel one of the main
contributors there at first things was
john paul ii english language biographer
i think had pretty privileged access to
him
so all that's to say the pope benedict
actually it might have been when he was
joseph ratzinger but he lectured at one
of the first things annual lectures
um
and so
you know i i feel like the the
conservative
uh chris catholic
uh movement in the united states their
relationship to to the vatican and the
papacy um underwent a massive shift
because of the rise of pope francis and
then you kind of add that into the rise
of trump and
and like the
uh you know just the
the politics of resentment in a certain
way you know gay marriage was legalized
by the supreme court and only what 2014
or 15 2015. you know so these were
pretty recent things that i think
and in the kind of you know i don't know
this
isn't meant to derail us at all but even
just the kind of
you know political correctness wokeness
put in quotes whatever you want like
their reactivity to that whatever you
make of the reality of the situation i
think was a huge factor and it i
i don't know what happens though to to
kind of
i don't know if anything i've said fully
explains it
you know but i think those are all in
play no no that's that's okay um i know
i think i mean that was very
comprehensive yeah no for sure i i so i
was thinking if maybe we could hone in
on like
kind of a theoretical point about like
liberalism
because like you know in conservatism
and i'd be interested to know and you
like when you were in those circles like
you yeah you know i think you mentioned
here and i listen to your part three and
other episodes you talk about you know
knowing a lot of these people personally
uh engaging with them probably
intellectually at the time
and you know maybe
you could talk a little bit about some
of these people's attitudes towards
philosophical liberalism
um because it seems like maybe that's
the new part of the post-labor maybe
it's not so new right maybe you'd have
some insight you said you were pretty
close to nin so i don't know if if that
ever came up in your
kind of conversations but what was sort
of
like in the intellectual conservatism's
attitude then and maybe like the shift
now to just like liberalism as kind of
this state neutrality i guess you know
maybe we define we can we have maybe we
don't have to define liberalism but kind
of philosophically what people think i'd
just like to make one follow-up to that
also which is that
this is the most robin s point i'm going
to make in this episode uh there's this
kind of presupposition on the part of a
lot of leftists and even along amongst
some intellectual conservatives uh like
russell kirk that conservatism just is
the stupid party uh as kirk put it in
the conservative mind right and
that it's a little more than
bigotry and reaction uh just kind of
jumble together into various apologies
but what's really interesting about the
work of the best conservative
intellectuals including i would argue
many of the post-liberals is that there
is a kind of intellectual cogency to
their project uh i mean i disagree with
it fundamentally and i've said so on
numerous occasions and i'll probably be
on beating that drum until they go
silent or i do but you know you read
patrick nean's book and it's
intellectually appealing it's exciting
it's well written you read adrian
vimelia's reads and book on common good
constitutionalism and he makes some very
good points against originalism of all
things that can make it appealing to
some people on the political level so
these aren't intellectual lightweights
in fact they're
making some
superficially interesting points
yeah
well i think thank you for that
matt which i i agree with um
you know it's and it's it's kind of
lousy that uh conservatives all being
dumb has become such a trope because it
allows them to begin every
every book every big essay by quoting
lino trilling the irritable mental
gestures resembling ideas right it's
like
we know we get it we remember guys you
know but this is like the 1950s you know
maybe update your references so but um i
do think that victor your point about
liberalism is interesting because i
would say
it did not have the place in the kind of
conservative imaginary and rhetorical
toolbox and and kind of the sets of
ideas they were they were playing with
it was there in some ways
um i mean but it was much more
nuanced i mean uh
uh like janine
was a student of the great uh wilson
carrie mcwilliams a long time professor
at rutgers who
had a really is this amazing big book he
put out in the early 70s called the idea
of fraternity in america
but it was it was not a sharp-edged
anti-liberalism it was more a
communitarian
like alternative to
uh
um
the most desiccated and kind of narrow
kinds of liberalism you know it's it
wouldn't be quite right say there was no
criticism of liberalism there but but
you know i i feel like some of the
people we're talking about came out of
the liberalism communitarian debates in
the 90s you know which were we're not
the tenor of i think what we're seeing
now and i'm not sure what accounts for
but i i do think
um here we can maybe bring in some
straussians i
i think the
the work of some of the claremont
uh
fellows around like
um
kind of
the nature of progressivism
and the progressive administrative state
it uh
and you kind of combine that with the
kind of existing straussian um like
three waves of modernity
right um
that kind of culminates or i should say
um crashes you know uh
with the holocaust and kind of
the horrors of world war ii and all that
right um so there are these there were
these narratives of decline on the right
that i think there was a straussian
iteration there's a voglinian iteration
of you know there's a uh you know it's
been put in different
registers and in slightly different ways
you know the some of the um you know
critiques of say nominalism
uh that you get from people like john
milbank uh who do like theology and
social theory or you know brad gregory
the unintended reformation which is like
all the ills of modernity come from
you know this wrong move which was the
reformation you know i i think it was
something where
uh
that combination an instinctive taste
for kind of narratives of decline
with then
liberalism increasingly becoming
formulated i think in the obama era
especially as
this kind of insatiable engine that
liberalism is not just this i think as
matt and i i know matt's work a little
bit on this better than yours victor but
you know for me being trained as a
political theorist it's made me
resistant to the very narrative some of
these people also political leaders are
offering because it's like well
liberalism is this long and you know
variegated tradition or you know
multi-multiple traditions maybe aspects
of multiple aspects of a tradition it's
very hard to locate it as or describe it
as this one monolithic thing that's
inexorably working its destiny out into
in the world um
and
but that's not so that's how i think
about liberalism and we could have a
conversation about say french liberalism
in the 19th century or you know uh
you know compare that to maybe a more
you know lockheed strain of liberalism
and you know but it's not just one thing
and it's
yeah you can't just give it a capital l
and declare it the enemy but it's kind
of what's what's happened so i think
you're right to locate
that um
uh as a
really signal thing here i mean it's
there in the name post-liberal but i can
honestly say
among all the conservative intellectuals
and these are academic types i'm talking
about the names we've already mentioned
not just like pundits or something yeah
would i describe them as you know
bourbon swelling uh people you know sit
on the patio bow ties with a cigar yeah
yeah yeah yeah
uh you know i just didn't hear
liberalism talked about in quite that
way it's not that again it was totally
unpresent but i i do think some of what
happened was
uh like like i will use the example of
patrick because this is a public
uh paper he gave it's it's not me
divulging anything but i do remember
this was the first inkling something had
gone wrong
uh with him was uh
he became this is like circa 2006 maybe
seven
really invested in peak oil theory
which is
like i'm not criticizing that per se
like obviously like there is ecological
crisis that we're in the midst of now
and oil's a huge part of it but it was
more this like that we're going to run
out of oil
shortly right
and it would be more a catastrophe for
human society and civilization which
sometimes you get the sense they long
for actually that okay there is a bit of
burn it all down but uh he actually i
remember it was the western political
science association conference which
amusingly was in las vegas that year
because i remember walking out of some
hotel and i just given a paper on
rousseau and there was like some like
i don't know weird like statue of a
woman in bronze like gold or bronze or
something another hotel and he was like
matt do you ever think you'd give a
paper rousseau in a hotel with a bronze
ass outside its front door you know
but he get that very confidence he gave
a talk on peak oil and political theory
and
uh the the taste for the more radical
catastrophe stuff
was clearly there with janine but he's
so he's one of the ones i'm not as
surprised by actually uh um but i think
more broadly yeah uh talk because you
know part of the old conservative
coalition was like classical liberalism
you know there was a way in which some
conservatives still would try to say no
we're the true liberals here that was in
the mix too but the kind of identifying
again liberalism as this
progressively unfolding
set of bad ideas that has a destiny in
the world
a certain terminus
that's i think newish and you can see
though the pieces of the puzzle that
they kind of put together they were all
there on the right there was the
narratives of decline there was you know
um a suspicion of at least certain kinds
of liberalism
and i think that events
and the pace of social change in some
aspects of our lives uh in our culture
along with like campus politics stuff
and
and it can't be goddamn it's modern
neo-marxists everywhere yeah yeah and i
think too once you
get a taste for
once some of these ideas they they put
them out into the world and they got a
lot of pushback i think that hardened
then the lines of um
uh
opposition you know like they became
more entrenched and dug down a bit
deeper uh because you know to to write
about some of these things in this
moment when
there is a crisis of democracy in the
united states right when when a lot in
our political order right now is up for
grabs you just start throwing out you
know some
pretty big
and uh far far-reaching ideas about why
liberalism which i and i think many
people associate whatever else you might
associate it with with individual rights
protections et cetera you start saying
well liberalism's the problem well what
parts of it and just what are you going
to get rid of yeah
you know yeah no i mean i spend a lot of
time people on the left that also right
yes there are a couple people who take
offense at uh even my calling myself a
liberal socialist but i always like yeah
do you really want to get rid of rights
to expression
rights association rights against
criminal limits on government power
i know victor's got a great question
though so good yes so no i mean i think
that's important too like like maybe
it'll come up again in the conversation
but i think what's interesting also on
the left is like sort of a especially a
lot of our listeners who who tend to
veer more towards like i guess like
post-modern like philosophy they're like
a lot of them are more interested in
like post-modern left philosophy figures
like darida and then like psychoanalysis
and you know we just did a series on on
the idea of communism which was like a a
series edited by slavoy zizek you know
so we were reading a couple papers by
people like jean-luc nancy so a lot of
our listeners are kind of in that circle
and i think a lot of them have a lot of
bad things to say about liberalism they
will also locate you know the problem
but so maybe we can come back to that
but
i think the narrative of decline is
really important and i think you know i
think that's sort of a lot of your
answer was sort of circling around uh
the narrative of decline and maybe that
can lead us into talking a little bit
more specifically about strozianism uh
if if you're up for it because i think
what's
i think like there is
you know uh maybe there's a narrative of
decline
uh in in some of that i don't know as
much about strozianism as you do
although i am at the university of
toronto uh you know where where there's
a bit of a history of course
yes
we have uh you know bloom was here for i
think all of the 70s and thomas pangla
was here until maybe like 15 years ago
and then we still got clifford or when
he's still totally still around him
um so there's a history at the
university of toronto so i have
colleagues you know who are sympathetic
to that but but i don't always know
exactly how what it is and maybe it's
come up on the podcast a little bit but
i think for the listeners it might be
interesting to kind of
you know both maybe try to explain like
what strozianism is doing and then also
i've heard you talk
on your podcast as well and maybe
written about the fact that you know as
a young intellectual
there's something that's really in
seductive and exciting about strozianism
uh and you know like maybe putting or
being able to put our thumb on what
exactly that is because a lot of our
listeners will be very excited about
some of the other philosophers that i
was talking about on the more
post-structural uh you know like
post-modern sign they find that really
exciting but strozianism i think hasn't
has a real exciting exciting seductive
aspect
um so maybe you could talk a little bit
about what that is as a way into just
sort of explaining what it is if we can
yeah sure because i think actually
there's there's kind of the same answer
to both
sides of your question which is that i
think at the simplest straussianism is a
way of reading texts
um i think you know there's a lot else
to say about it but um i you know i do
think
it's taken on
sometimes for better reasons than others
but
an era of the dangerous you know um if
you go back
to
[Music]
say uh the discourse
around the start of the iraq war and the
bush administration in the supposed
neocon straussian influence
uh on it you know
where you know it wasn't just
straussians like people trained by
people who were trained by leo strauss
it was like kind of going back to the
masters texts and finding the iraq war
you know in the moments that's a bit of
an exaggeration but i i it did make me
you know think come on this is really
you know
it's not that none of that is present in
straussianism or but you know to me it
is fundamentally a way of reading text
and that's why it's so seductive
uh as a kind of like political theory
nerd smart maybe maybe conservative
leaning but maybe not necessarily um i
think it's it's
you know the conservative minded student
is more likely to be sympathetic to
thinking wisdom is found in old books
but it's not a
necessary right uh but but no joe and
actually sorry quickly i want to
actually just to add to that it's uh you
know one of my colleagues a good friend
of mine actually from my program
he's this australian guy and he came in
and he didn't even know that strauss was
like associated with conservatism he
just liked that way of reading the text
so he was just into plato he came to
work with clifford orwin and he's kind
of apolitical yeah i try to talk to him
about politics and he's like yeah i
don't know like he just seems nominally
left but just more interested about in
the text yeah yeah that's a that's a
real thing i'm not totally shocked you
say that at all
um
but you know to go beyond that uh um you
know i mentioned the three waves of
modernity essay of strauss's even that's
something that's contested how to read
that was strauss saying the waves are
necessarily one fall on the other or is
it you know just one way it could go um
or one way it did go uh you know so uh
part of the reason it's hard to pin
straw seedism down is strauss himself
was hard to pin down in some ways and
you know uh
but to maybe then
in lieu of a definition i'll just kind
of mention some of his books that or
ideas and categories so like a big
strauss set of straussian categories are
the ancients in the moderns
right um
uh uh with with the moderns picking up
with you know maybe machiavelli um
hobbes you know strauss did a lot of
work on both of those figures uh some of
them only which recently meaning
in my time hasn't all been translated
into english some of his stuff on hobbs
and the theological political problem
and things like that so it's it's you
know you have ancients and moderns you
have reason and revelation athens and
jerusalem um and and you know strauss
was concerned i think a lot with the
nature of
the philosophical quest the search for
truth what was possible but you know
human for human reason to accomplish
and um you know political philosophy was
always interesting i i mean i think
political philosophy is a special
interest to strauss in straussians
because it was like
politics is the arena in which like
the different aspects of our nature and
our search for truth are like amplified
or given concrete expression in some way
in addition to politics being a kind of
architect tonic science right
um
yes um but so you know i think it's one
way strauss was
it would probably be fair to describe as
a partisan of the ancients against the
moderns if you had to put it broadly um
and uh you know but another aspect of
his thought is you know
esoteric writing
uh
uh so you know in regimes where uh
toleration and kind of freedom of
expression are where persecution is the
title's book persecution the art of
writing indicates you know uh
philosophers would have to embed kind of
their true message
uh in a text by you know the attentive
reader being able to pick up on the
discrepancies or seeming contradictions
and uh the the philosophical writer and
reader the the the writer will kind of
use those contradictions to
point you to what he
is actually trying to say
um
uh and of course and of course strauss
was also i i should this has been too
abstract i'm sorry i mean strauss was
someone who uh we're all about abstract
here yeah was but uh exiled from from
germany uh of course with the rise of
nazism he was jewish so uh there's been
interesting work done on strauss as like
an exile figure of you know what that
means for his philosophy uh his very his
interest in in of course jewish uh texts
and
uh
questions maimonides
spinoza uh figures like that uh
you know so he's he's in that kinda he's
a jewish german philosopher exile
refugee who then you know i i think in a
lot of his work
you can that's in the background say uh
one of his most famous books is natural
right in history
um
the title gives it away like
you know natural right versus like more
historicist modes of thing yeah but uh
he begins by talking about the
declaration of independence and how
american adherence to it means there's
some
you know spark of natural right thinking
that there's objective right and wrong
that not everything is subject to
history
um
in historical change and therefore kind
of relativism uh you know and then he
starts talking about germany and how
they don't believe that anymore and he
kind of like is indicating that like
historicism
caused the holocaust or led up to it or
it was a contributing factor
um so he he you know uh i think his
context is important to realize too
um and actually could you um could you
like unpack historicism a little bit
more because i think that is like really
important and also links to
maybe like understanding why
conservatism is so or like how there's a
marriage between conservatism and
strozianism maybe because there is from
what i understand as you you put it in
that book kind of
there maybe that it's not a conflation
but there is a link between what you
were talking about historicism and then
relativism which i think you quickly
mentioned which is obviously like the
enemy yeah of like you know
conservatives want to find eternal
truths
or like a historic maybe that's changed
now with matt's work in in post-modern
conservatism but still yeah um this is
where i just want to add a little
wrinkle to that though because one of
the things that's frequently
misunderstood about that book uh is
perceiving his critique of historicism
is primarily directed against left-wing
uh thinkers you know the marks yeah
arguably it's all about burke yeah
exactly right i mean he locates the
origin of historicism and neither of
those two people but in edmund burke
where he says he's the one who started
all these major problems and
that's a pretty remarkable statement uh
i actually think it's a pretty important
statement when you think about whether
historicism has to lean left let's just
put it crudely that way yeah but another
major figure who's often perceived to be
in the background of the text and here's
where that esoteric uh esoteric kind of
distinction might be important a lot of
people see the book as him
coming to terms with and even critiquing
heidegger uh who was such a huge
influence on him later joined the nazi
pro
party and it was seen at least by
strauss and you know i'm sure there's a
lot of gearings out there who will be
slamming the fist down
as
developing a very robust and very
sophisticated kind of historicism in his
own work so could you talk a little bit
about that because this really shows how
complicated strauss is as a figure
because yeah there are definitely
conservative elements to that book but
no book that starts by saying you know
burke is the squadron of all of our
intellectual problems is unambiguously
right
totally totally um
and you know this is a source of uh
don't worry i will circle back to that
but i just just kind of give a sense of
this really does matter um yeah you know
it's a great book by the way i should
say everyone should read it yeah yeah i
mean if you look at some of the disputes
uh early in the conservative
intellectual movement in the 50s and 60s
someone like russell kirk more
associated with
well i mean
he was a
i think he wrote a book about burke
burke's the hero of the conservative
mind right the the kind of great
conservative figure for him the genius
of conservatism right yeah uh but
someone but other figures like no you
need natural rights you need
you know uh tradition isn't enough
especially when you live in a time when
tradition has gone off the rails right
uh if what's come to be
um is bad then the tradition isn't
enough you need some kind of principles
that transcend you know the flux of
history
uh the evolution of tradition etc to
anchor your political project um
so
the kind of
debate that the dichotomy strauss sets
up there has echoed through
you know even far lower brow uh
conservative disputes
um but yeah historicism would be that
there's just no truth that transcends
the flux of history right that uh a
trans-historical transcendent truth um
now you know
how much of that strauss thought we
could get i don't really
it that's an open question you know um
how much was he at the end of the day
you'd stare into the abyss and that's
all that's there you know or is there
really something
you can hold on to in some sense uh i
don't know it's kind of like a disputed
reading of strauss like was he just you
know uh
secretly an atheist nihilist who didn't
really think you know any of this could
really you could really pin any of this
down uh that's you know
i think some of strauss's own
ambiguities is why you have different
schools of thought uh that come out of
it you have west coast straussian's
associated like the claremont institute
the claremont review of books that
you know uh are very a huge part of the
trumpist movement but they're the ones
who talk about natural rights and really
think that like the american founding
was in a fairly uncomplicated way
uh you know
you know the work of genius men who we
can't improve upon basically to be good
uh genius slaveholders you know right
yeah uh-huh that just made me a bit of a
[ __ ] but you know i i like to stress
that but there's more you know i think
as uh the east coast straussians that
are a bit more skeptical uh their
political interventions sometimes are
you know uh not as straightforward um
and you know they're a bit less pious in
multiple senses of the word um
so
uh
you know i think again i'm just trying
to say that i'm a bit out of my depths
here and strauss is a complicated figure
and i'm not trying to sort of you know
put my foot down on one side or the
other but more to say these are some of
the categories and themes that work in
him and historicism especially was one
that you know it is i think for him
linked to something like relativism once
you say there's really no truth that
transcends you know just
you know the ups and downs of our
evolution the formation of tradition
over time everything's historically
conditioned might be the better way to
say it is there any way to ever get out
of being
you know uh to reach beyond your moment
uh in history um
you know that that's
uh
how he would talk about it in some of
the books we've referenced like natural
right in history
matt i know you want to ask a follow-up
but just quickly i want to add and then
just to like bring it back to like the
ancients i guess the reason why there's
an attraction to the ancients is because
is that a way to kind of demonstrate
that there are these eternal human
problems or whatever that and like like
by going back to to the ancients somehow
like that's to capture something that is
not historical yes historicism they did
philosophy the right way
because they they
again in this reading you know thought
you could the human mind actually could
you know uh uh kind of raise itself up
beyond just
just uh everything that's around you and
historically conditioning your thought
um but also you know i mean
plato especially
i think is more important to straussians
than than aristotle in some ways
depending on the on the one but the
dialogue format also i think is very
attractive to them because it it again
if you're looking for kind of esoteric
reading between the lines like dialogue
is a good format to do that and they
have some very fascinating and kind of
interesting reads of the platonic
dialogues
um and
uh so it's both like i think
they did philosophy right and
there's a certain
uh i i don't know it's it's kind of like
uh uh the real in addition to being
great readers of books close readers of
text uh that the if you the smarter
straw scenes that i knew would be very
adept at like
toggling between talking about a
platonic dialogue and then some
contemporary flash point
and kind of you know like uh it's very
seductive because it feels like oh yeah
there's this like
you know
uh
grand
ancient knowledge yeah yeah this pool of
ancient wisdom that we've just been
ignoring and you know there's some truth
to that actually but you know um
that's part of
i think the seductiveness of
straussianism too the best of them it's
really uh
a heady mix of being able to read
different languages go back to the
ancients kind of have this critique of
early modern thought and and kind of the
origins of modernity and you're mixing
in kind of cultural commentary and they
all wear fancy suits and when you finish
your doctorate with harvey mansfield he
gives you the number of his tailor in
london you know
well i have to say like that's true
that's true by the way
yeah like it's odd because um the first
graduate level political theory class i
ever took uh was at carlton with waller
e newell uh who is the most important
straussian in the department and he's
actually become pretty famous uh i saw
him on netflix the other day talking
about tyranny because he released a book
on that recently a good book i should
say
but you know there really was this idea
of being kind of inculcated into
a privileged cadre of people who read
texts and do read between the lines to
get to the secrets of them and read them
closely so that you can access the
profound truths that's
extremely intoxicating uh if you're
absolutely yeah what young person
wouldn't be told i know right yeah i
mean and that's i'm not sitting there to
kind of bash by saying you know there's
just you know some ragtag man behind the
curtain because i do think that
straussians are good readers of text but
i did want to touch a little bit about
this methodological point before we move
on to something that's more political
because i think it's really important
for our listeners who might not be
familiar with strauss
and you know there's a lot of ambiguity
about this so we're not going to settle
that here but he does have this very
interesting distinction between an
exoteric uh reading of the text and an
esoteric interpretation of the text uh
and this seems to sit uncomfortably with
what some people call strauss's golden
statement uh which is that everything is
on the surface right you shouldn't be
sitting there looking for depth beneath
the surface because it's on the surface
and only on the surface uh that the
truth or the heart of things lie
and my way of reading this passage and
again the people probably out there who
are going to say i'm entirely wrong
about this is that he is criticizing
this historicization of texts that a lot
of people engage in right now uh you
know he was very influenced by nietzsche
and heidegger both of them would sit
there and say well you read the text in
the context of
what that person's pathology is or what
the culture surrounding them is and
strauss is just saying no you know read
the book itself because these were smart
guys and not only were they
self-conscious about
what they were writing they were
self-conscious about how they were
writing it because they're layers to the
text that you can unpack that are
deliberately put there uh by the author
and you need the kind of key to get at
them would you say that this is right or
yeah no and i i'm so glad you mentioned
that because the other reason especially
for undergraduates or early graduate
students i think stressing can be
seductive is because
it's a direct confrontation with the
text yeah like you don't sit there and
be like let's historicize it you don't
have to know that
yeah histori her you know the author's
biography the entire you know political
history cultural context of the moment
that produced this text etc and and it's
kind of saying if you're a smart reader
you can you can really spend time with
this text and pay attention to it
closely and get out of it deep wisdom
too you know and so it's a very i think
the methodological point is actually
partly why it's so seductive too because
it's and i think you're right matt that
the the comment you could misread the
comment about surfaces from strauss as
being
uh encountered intention or
contradiction with an esoteric but i
think you're right it's actually taking
aim at a kind of death of the author
you know uh terminus of suspicion yeah
yeah lose lose the text for in in the
midst of so much context kind of thing
yeah i mean i've seen a lot of scenes
criticize people like nietzsche for
example on that basis because they'll
say you didn't even bother to argue
against plato uh the way that
would argue against the sofis he just
sat there and pathologized plato by
saying that this moral hunger was really
at the basis of all of your books
and so this kind of pollutes any
argument that you put forward and you
know maybe there's some legitimacy to
that but you know kind of moving along
and i don't want to because i'm really
interested in these questions and i'm
reading a lot of stuff right now well
can i just make can i just make one more
point about strozianism before we move
on i think
the last i guess the i guess the last
thing because we were kind of been
talking about how
like why it's seductive to you know
young people and then eventually like i
guess who end up being conservatives but
maybe we'll return to that but i guess
what i'm
what i think is also really interesting
is i guess though the way that it seems
like strozianism puts the intellectual
at the center puts the philosopher at
the center like because it seems to me
that there's there's a level of
weightiness and importance that maybe
isn't present in other
philosophical traditions of how
important the philosopher actually is to
society and of course if you're someone
who's
gonna maybe be a philosopher well that's
also i think a very seductive idea too
that like you're the most important
you're doing the most important profound
work so maybe you could say something
about that yeah no i think that's uh a
good point to add as well i think
it is i mean it's not surprising when
you think about everything we've just
said but
being self-conscious about being a
philosopher
in
in the city
you know
how does the philosopher how does the
person doing this work relate to
um you know the society the city they're
a part of that you know has its own
prejudices that the the philosopher you
know um
this is the old story of socrates right
that the philosopher may corrupt the
youth against or you know um with their
skeptical inquiry
um
you know uh undo confidence and
certainty in you know so i think they
are very aware of the straus of the
philosopher's role
in in the broader political and social
context and that's a big part of um i
think the way they think yeah
good
awesome and then i don't know i don't
know matt where you wanted to move on
but like i guess maybe just adding those
things together to sort of the reason
why i guess because you know i feel like
everything we've said
wouldn't necessarily like unless like um
mean that the people who read these
texts are gonna are gonna be
conservative and as you said you know
it's not necessarily true that a lot of
strozians are but i guess we can maybe
see or like outline a little bit the
reasons why it is is i guess one thing
would be like you know to review like
the the being sort of against this sort
of like historicism or this kind of
relativistic view which i think like
left-wing politics nowadays tends to not
always but tends to
kind of like to talk about the
situatedness of everything right and
even even now in like woke language
right you talk about everyone's um
positionality right everything is
contextual and i think like strozianism
clearly is something that's saying like
no there are eternal human
true or like like uh there are eternal
human truths that you can discover by
reading these texts to get to know
humanity so that's one way in which i
think it's attractive to conservatism
i'm not sure matt matt or matt
either of you like have additional
thoughts about why it's
or is that no
that's exactly the question i want to
ask just because i wanted to move us on
to okay the influence was joust on
politics um but i do think that you're
absolutely right that
one of the influences of straussianism
at least in the united states and i
think the case is a little bit different
in europe uh and for that matter even in
the uk
has been to really deflate attempts to
build a kind of historicist argument
for uh you know american conservatism uh
i mean the major kind of
players in right-wing intellectualism
right now at least in the united states
all adhere to this idea that
transcendence uh are important right you
need a transcended source of value in
order to anchor your viewpoint
and
this can seem pretty abstract but
sometimes it can get really concrete uh
arguably the most
influential straussian at least in the
1980s was alan bloom uh who wrote a book
called the closing of the american mind
which you guys did a great episode on uh
but you know one of the things that he
brought up again and again and again is
that he was encountering these students
who adopted what he called the kind of
easy relativism that he associated with
liberalism uh they were open-minded but
in this very shallow way because they
weren't really committed to believing
anything uh so they weren't open-minded
in the sense that they were waiting to
adopt a certain attitude towards the
truth but just because they were
dispassionate or disinterested in the
whole idea of truth whatsoever and he
argued that this is a big serious
problem and we need to rethink how it is
that we teach students in a university
system so there's ways of bringing this
stuff down to a very concrete level and
it's important because this book of
course is usually considered a
touchstone and starting off
this really ugly culture war that
dominates the headlines right now
and you can also see the the seeds of
like kind of the narratives of decline
too you can kind of see the way that
that that adds that waters the seeds of
decline of the narrative of decline yes
and and let's not forget in closing i
mean it's the german
university that is the bug bear for him
right um
but you know uh
to matt's point him and him and uh mick
jagger right the other great enemy of
you know right right
uh-huh um but i think that
i want to say this is strauss's own term
but i i could be wrong about that but
the what matt just described bloom
picking up on
uh uh
is i think the phrase is the cave
beneath the cave
right if the shadows on the wall in the
cave are just like your prejudices but
you're so kind of easygoing and tolerant
you don't even have like strong
prejudices that the philosopher can push
off against right that will be the
fodder for the socratic dialogue if
you're just too blase about everything
to even have strong convictions to to
kind of
wrestle with you're in the cave beneath
the cave um i just always loved that
line and so i wanted to put it in here
but yeah for sure i would say you know
matt mentioned how blooms were kind of
touched down in the american culture
wars in the 80s and into the 90s um i
think another thing
to give something practical just because
i feel this pressure uh since uh
isn't ultimately an uh uh academic
podcast so you know i i have this
instinct but
you throw the word ontology around like
you know other people talk about star
wars yeah
but i think a very practical example is
and i was thinking about this because of
the supreme court's recent decision
overturning roe uh
and someone like i think robbie george's
amicus brief even
argued for finding fetal personhood in
the 14th amendment
uh and one of the things i realized over
time in my own like
hanging out with these people like i
mean i i hung out with robbie george
some i hung out with hadley archusam
but i also you know knew more
traditionalist berkey and types like my
old teacher at georgetown george w carey
who was a friend of wilmore kendall's
and
uh was a scholar of the federalists in
in the american constitution but like he
was you know held up that other end of
the spectrum is when it comes to
judicial interpretation
there's actually a
substantial critique of originalism for
being historicist and just being well
really being positivist just that you
know you you look at the meaning of the
words you know and and maybe you look up
their history in context but it's you
know there's no undergirding
morality
underneath the constitution that you can
draw from and someone like hadley arkis
would say no like like you have to read
the constitution in light of the
declaration which presupposes that um
[Music]
you know the human mind has access to
certain truths and among them are the
rights that government is instituted to
protect and so uh i think
uh you can see how even something like
constitutional interpretation like uh
critics of historicism
uh uh would
you know sometimes run afoul of the
originalists who do all the historical
work figuring out what you know right to
bear arms meant to the average person in
1789 or something right
no i should say that's sometimes made
very explicit like in his latest book
common good constitutionalism uh adrian
v miller kind of follows up on his
atlantic article by saying uh we all
knew he's speaking here to other
conservatives that originalism was an
intellectually bankrupt project it had
useful kind of rhetorical purposes uh in
advancing conservative causes during an
age where liberal positivism and liberal
democracy uh were kind of ascendant but
you know we're now in a position to just
kind of drop it and
legislate from the bench and we should
adopt my common common good
constitutionalism as the framework uh to
kind of guide kind of kind of kind of a
badly timed book in a way
yeah i mean a lot of conservatism on
twit uh conservatives on twitter got
really angry at him um some of whom i
think really are committed to
originalism um
and yeah but talk about that some of the
time but i mean it was really shocking
just to see somebody
kind of state transparently what i think
a lot of us felt for a long time
yeah but i mean was it poorly timed
because there are limits to what
originalism can do
positively speaking like i think
original is good at striking down roe
because you
bring in all these arguments about
deeply rooted rights and traditions in
american history blah blah blah right
that's original is good at striking down
supposed uh
activist legal cases and decisions uh
but now you know maybe they want the
court to do more and maybe they wanted
to find
a right to fetal personhood in the 14th
amendment and originalism might not
really get you there
yeah that's what you need whatever they
say that's true yeah
um but you know i think another
uh kind of connection to more today's
day-to-day conservatism
was something that i noticed a lot at
the start of the pandemic and i wrote i
actually wrote a piece for the bias the
institut of christian socialism
publication and a piece for tnr the new
republic about this which is i noticed
how striking it was
that something like whether or not to
wear masks this is in the first month of
the pandemic right or months where it
was
controversial like that was a big thing
right we didn't have vaccines yet
uh so they had to find something to to
gripe about and it was the mask wearing
but they would often pitch it as
this is what happens when a society
rejects god
secularism sets in people uh no longer
believe in an afterlife so death is what
they fear most of all a godless people
fears that was our arena's peace in
first things like almost to a t right
like yes we're a culture that's so
afraid of death now that we just hide
from it you know like yeah so asking
people to wear masks
during a pandemic was rendered as
the inevitable outcome of a secular
society uh and and the pathologies that
would attend to it mostly like people
just trying to stay healthy as long as
they can and not die um and that fear
that that lack of or that fear of death
comes from not believing god and you can
see that there's this is like i do think
that the the kind of narrative of
decline in catastrophe is such a huge
part of the conservative
self-understanding and consciousness in
the united states these days it's you
know uh when it comes with uh you know
even abortion one thing we we talked
about a lot in our episodes about roe
was among the kind of christian
conservative intellectuals who were
opposed to abortion it was like
you know connected to the holocaust
uh you know explicitly uh
and and kind of a terminus of
this long decline
uh and a lot of issues when you think
about are
put in this like this is what like
same-sex marriage you know trans
transgender people like it's it's never
just a discreet
political issue that
you know is just one thing you can think
about uh and try to do your best on like
masks were just not
um a way to try to stop the spread of a
of a virus that at that point we had no
vaccine for very few treatments for and
that we're filling our hospitals
including i lived in new york you know
uh
freezer trucks outside the morgues
because the morgues were too full right
so the masculine was just not like
people trying to stay safe during a time
of extreme danger
it was
the dunuma of
you know uh something that happened
three centuries ago when societies
decided to
you know reject god or something i know
and i mean there is something that
sometimes gets a little bit darkly funny
about this i mean i remember reading the
r arena piece uh what you later
apologized for because you got kovit and
said you know it sucks
maybe don't go that far
so you know
just to be fair let's point that out but
you know you kind of sit there and think
like oh so your whole argument right now
is that i'm getting tired of people
being so worried about dying you know
let's just
back away from those concerns for a
little bit you think like jesus you know
this is just getting a little bit over
the top but i want us to shift a little
bit to
kind of more concrete issues uh because
we've talked a lot about conservative
intellectuals uh
some of the kind of cutting edge in
american conservatism at least this kind
of straussian basis in this post-liberal
basis but what some of the interesting
things that comes through and know your
enemy uh is
how important these conservative
intellectuals are to giving a kind of
gloss uh to mainstream conservatism and
also how fun well funded they are that's
something that people are a little bit
less familiar with uh because one of the
things that you know you talk about on
know your enemy is how if you're kind of
conservative intellectual you know 22 25
with some talent uh and they think that
you have a future then there are forums
in place that will kind of skyrocket you
to the front of the national
consciousness and
i'm not really sure that there are
similar avenues available to on the left
uh which i think is
not as not as well organized
i'm thinking immediately think of our
mutual i guess guest on the show nate
hochman right or he was he was in our
show but i mean nate's genuinely a
really smart and very articulate guy i
mean sure but i'm just saying he's a
good example of someone who is like kind
of on the
he's he's being groomed and pushed
forward to be the you know the future
i mean i sometimes just wish we did more
of that on the left or we had the
institutions in place to kind of do that
or achieve that because they're very
very successful at it so i'm wondering
if you could just talk a little bit
about that you know how do you take
these kind of intellectual energies put
these people in a position where they
can actually develop an ideological
justification for what the party is
doing uh or the movement is doing
however you want to characterize it and
how important is that do you think
yeah you know it's it's been an
interesting uh
in the trump era uh phrase i hate to use
but you know i i think there's been a
lot of rightful
um
interrogation of kind of the
historiography of conservatism
and
you know uh if you look at say george
h nash's the conservative intellectual
move in america 1945 to whatever the
latest edition is um you know it's very
centered around national review and
there's a way in which you know you can
tell the story of
american conservatism in the in the
second half of the 20th century as like
a small band of intellectuals started a
few magazines
and
uh
yeah yeah bill buckley and frank meyer
and they just single-handedly restarted
the conservative movement yeah and it
somehow all like crescendoed in you know
ronald reagan's election in 1980 right
uh and you know i think a lot of
historians have drawn us to the rougher
edges of conservatism the nastier more
populist movements and elements that
were fueling the right um you know even
some of the first things i wrote about
trump during the
republican primary debates in 2015-16 i
got riding the trump tiger you know like
there is a sense which these
intellectuals have always
you know kind of uh
i think had to clean up the more popular
energies they they hope their movement
and politicians can ride to power um
sometimes you know try to disown them a
bit but it's you know the the interplay
between ideas and and you know more
popular movements and grassroots
movements is an interesting one and by
talking about ideas i don't want to
necessarily totally privilege them but i
will say the conservative movement which
includes you know not just the ideas
people but think tanks and activist
groups and you know um
uh single-issue groups
and a lot of money it's a very small
movement and so i do think the ideas
have particular power on the right
because
um because of that uh like look at some
of the national conservatism conferences
if you look at you know uh say the one
that was in florida uh maybe this fall
uh whenever that was uh i think it was
this fall
uh you know you would have politicians
there like jd vance and ted cruz maybe
uh but you know
someone like uh
at these conferences maybe not that one
in particular but there are editor
magazines like rusty reno editor of
first things rich lowry editor of
nashville review um someone from this
publication some from that publication
and also people involved in various like
capital hill
organizations uh you know who do
lobbying and maybe more grassroots stuff
are there too and so you can see that
like the ideas people in the politicians
and then some of the more grassroots uh
pressure group types are
are in the same rooms hashing things out
and so i think ideas have real purchase
on the right in a very particular way
because of again i think the relative
smallness
of the movement in that sense i mean
even you just mentioned nate hoffman
sometimes nate will ask me something i'm
like oh yeah i knew him in grad school
or he's like do you know did you know
everyone i was like well kind of but not
because i was special but because if you
were in the movement you would basically
know everyone you know or be very one
degree of separation from someone
and and so i uh you know that's
important to note but they do have a lot
of money and because like
you know i would say it's fair that most
people who go into graduate programs are
not like dedicated conservatives
most phd students aren't like dedicated
right-wing you know movement types but
if you are that's such a rarity and
they're so they are for all their
protestation so hungry for the
validation of elite institutions and you
know having people in some of these
perches that the just the money i got in
grad school even was
you know um an extra five grand here an
extra 10 grand there uh you know had i
needed like
you know i had a fellowship where i ta
and everything so i didn't need like my
tuition paid but uh you know i could
have gotten that taken care of too
and you know uh even
you know at a certain point in
your career like i do remember uh
i was teaching at uva on like a
dissertation fellowship i was under jim
caesar
uh well-known conservative uh
straussian uh
political theorist slash kind of does
american political development
uh you know he was kind of my my mentor
and you know there would be like
two-week summer programs at the boards
head in outside of charlottesville where
like for maybe a week or two there would
be
they would bring in just all the star
kind of straussian professors
uh but also
people who gave it mainstream
credibility gordon wood for example i
remember really showing up in peter
onoff uh scholar of jefferson you know
like there was a um really serious and
you get a really nice stipend and live
high in the hong for like two weeks at
this basically resort happy hours every
night and you'd mingle with
you know people who could really help
you
you know
senior academic types who who you know
whose views were at least roughly you
know similar to yours and uh the kind of
again the the way they support people
materially like giving them money
uh
as you know to make it in academia there
might be a period of time if you do i
mean it's such a horrific scene these
days and but like one key would be just
can you
good idea starting a podcast if you're
struggling right can you support
yourself along the way enough until you
maybe you get that break and so postdocs
became a major feature of this movement
the the jack miller center was through
these seminars i mentioned were often
through but they would then sponsor post
docs at various
elite institutions so
you know uh having a postdoc at uva or
harvard i mean harvey mansfield had i
think one of the original um
uh one of these postdocs that his
program on constitution and government
or something like government and
constitutional right
all these right-wing outfits they always
have the most innocuous names the more
bland the name the more likely it is
actually that it's conservative run i
think uh but you know that was i mean
look at the federalist society right i
mean yeah you can make a compelling
argument at this point that it basically
dominates uh american judicial politics
at this point if you were just here the
federalist society like oh that's the
kind of camping group they like to go
back to american revolutionary war sites
or something like that right
yeah so just just the support i had as a
young and this is why i say i'm not an
embittered ex-conservative i was treated
very well people were very generous to
me and if anything i feel guilty about
that you know uh like you know i i'm
i hate that people who are really kind
to me
um now feel betrayed someone like janine
right just really do they oh yeah like
without getting personalized
i mean i'm perfectly
i i would still talk to any of these
people but like someone deneen i am on
genuinely bad terms with i think
he's blocked me on twitter for example
oh wow okay
yeah that's i mean that's too bad i mean
are there any that like you still like
are on good terms with and they just
like respectfully they're like well yeah
you had a difference of opinion now and
like that's how it goes uh i mean it's
just because of the work i do i'm not
regularly in touch with these people but
like someone like uh jim caesar
at uva uh i mean i haven't really been
in touch with him for a while but i
loved him he was
probably i can honestly say he might be
the most socratic
individual i've ever personally known
uh in terms of what conversations with
him you know in his office or over
dinner were like so i have you know
i
i just don't have any i mean i have
profound disagreements but i really
don't have personal hostility to almost
any of these people uh but it's just
kind of drifting apart but um but that's
just to say i again i was treated very
well and i i you know i it really is
about the
the principles i came to believe and
where my convictions led me because if i
can honestly say i'm on the left now i'm
you know i i i mentioned being on
descent's editorial board like i kind of
really know that
the amount of money floating around
the right is is both it's a lot for the
number of people involved but also
they're much better at no strings
attached
uh i i want to start a center at
university x and you know uh you're not
gonna have to do
the same kind of
application you might for like a
progressive
non-profit that gives out grants where
you're you know you're gonna have to
have these metrics in a certain way i
don't know uh it's i'm not very deep in
that world but there's a real sense in
which like
you know uh if you wanted this money
you'd do a proposal but you know you
would know someone at the earhart
foundation or the thomas w smith
foundation someone and someone that they
know would have told them you know oh
this person's going to be applying and
like pretty much you're all set from
yeah because giving money to
uh intellectual endeavors is is a hard
sell because if you if you if you're a
rich person and you want to give money
to something probably a lot of them want
their name on it
right so if you if you if you give
enough money for a building
on a campus and you get your name on the
front of it that's going to be there for
a long time if you sponsor some you know
if you give a descent magazine 50 grand
to pay writers for the next few years
you might have your like you know at the
bottom of the article this this article
was supported by a grant from
blah blah blah that's not the same as
having your name on a building right so
yeah i think even you know there's
there's but but when you're when people
are really genuinely ideologically
invested as they are on the right i
think
just kind of giving money no strings
attached or with very few strings
attached is a more
it just happens more often i don't think
there's anything disingenuous about this
i mean i've sometimes seen iterations of
this argument that run oh the right is
basically co-opting uh these talented
young students and turning them into
little conservatives by essentially
bribing them i think that's a little bit
too cynical um but i do think that there
is something to be special politically
uh about this kind of approach to things
uh i mean just to give a contrast uh i
was speaking to megan day um i think it
was making day it might have been um
journalists with jacob yeah about jacob
and they're like you know we have a tiny
little office with a handful of
full-time writers and a lot of us barely
make ends meet in the cities that we're
working on current affairs which is
arguably the second largest uh socialist
magazine in the country has two
full-time staff members right uh two
right uh and you can kind of contrast
that with some of these think tanks
where
you know there's
good liquor and you know good food and
you can get you know harvard props will
come and get their business cards and
they'll write letters of reference for
you
it's a pretty appealing deal uh if you
happen to seems like a more much more
interesting club yeah and you know if
you happen to be you know smart and
talented and you're leaning in that
direction anyway uh it's certainly not
a bad thing to have these opportunities
be opened up for you and then once you
get into that circle it can be pretty
hard to disentangle yourself yeah no
totally
i think um actually it's funny there's
there's one of my colleagues i think
she's working on like hobbs and and some
some other
other early moderns and you know i think
her supervisor was like oh you should
apply to this thing i think it's like
the center for liberal studies or it's
like basically
this is more libertarian yeah movie
institute for liberal studies and she's
like you know they've got all this koch
brothers money and it's like you know
just go it's okay if you don't agree
with them just take the money and run
it's like worth it right and like i
think that just goes to your point that
they are just willing to dispense yeah
like money to people even if they don't
really care uh like that much they're
not gonna like
test you ideologically they just want
more people participating in their stuff
to make it bigger that's kind of like
the the flip side to it you know so the
really dedicated ones are really treated
quite well but also like something like
the institute for humane studies i mean
i'm glad matt kind of brought up it's
not as insidious as it might seem
because it's
one thing i've tried to say in the
pockets is it's all straightforward none
of it's not like
you know uh chicanery
uh
really
you know crazy secret stuff it's all
extremely straightforward and kind of a
goat's head or something and they're
like congratulations you're a member of
this yeah
yeah yeah and uh the the institute for
humane studies is a kind of classical
liberal libertarian outfit so associated
with george mason they would do a lot of
summer programs that were specifically
meant to just
uh they didn't want necessarily
just the true believers that's actually
that's the place i'm talking i'm
thinking of actually that is the place
because the point is not for you to
become a libertarian the point is for
you to think huh you know i really
should have some hayek
on my syllabus i really should have some
um uh you know thinker x y or z uh
robert nozick whatever you know whatever
kind of text might be applicable it's
it's not just to to convert people or
win them over with your money it's to
just kind of plant the seed that these
are serious ideas and that if you're an
academic who wants to kind of give your
students a
a sense of the range of opinion on
things or or bring in new and different
kinds of texts
it'll give you a good introduction to
some possibilities sure make sense i
wanted to bring it maybe back to maybe
start moving in the direction of
wrapping up
um back to sort of like left-wing
politics and
i wonder what you think sort of about
like strategically because we've been
talking about
you know as you've said this may be not
as uh insidious uh kind of
infrastructure that the right has and
then
so there's both maybe a question about
like practical organizing like maybe
what can like left-wing intellectuals do
better but then the other question would
also be more
philosophical which is
you know i think like there's something
like like nowadays
with what people call i guess the woke
discourse it just does seem like there's
there's less and less
uh
uh or they're at least being accused um
of being less and less connected to some
sort of like fundamental truth you know
this this accusation of relativism which
you know has various degrees of truth
various degrees of it just being kind of
like propagandistic you know
uh distortion but i guess like do you
see like
left like how important do you see like
left-wing left-wing politics left-wing
theory having some connection to
something to some like grounded truth
and obviously maybe that's a loaded
question for someone who who's
religiously inclined but just
rhetorically because it just feels like
right now
um
it can it can feel disorienting in
left-wing circles with like what kinds
of claims are there are they actually
making like what things are they
focusing on to actually make it make
give it broad appeal it'll be intuitive
to people you know working-class people
from you know places where you're from
right like central pennsylvania and just
to kind of follow it up you know with an
anecdote you know when i was doing my
phd you know my background was in human
rights mainly you know i'd been in
amnesty international a number of
different things but i took a class with
a bunch of post-structuralists and i
brought up issues like i asked you know
what is justice in this kind of context
what would be the right thing to do and
the teacher sat there and was like we're
not really concerned about that you know
nobody should be so arrogant as to
presume what is just and what is unjust
so
that's a kind of strong example and i
don't want to imply that
everyone you encounter in kind of
left-wing university circles is like
that because they're not but you can
definitely be embedded in this
environment that somebody like bloom is
talking about and if you're on the left
like i eventually became it can be kind
of disheartening to think like oh these
kinds of big t
you know capital t truth capital j
justice questions are just things i
shouldn't be interested in
yeah um well you know i think there's a
couple different ways i could try to
answer this and i think one of them is
uh
that i think builds up both of what you
said but victor you mentioned kind of
like the rhetorical problem like a very
practical political problem how do you
talk about these things in an
intelligible way and it's funny i just
had lunch earlier this week with a
friend of mine who
uh works a lot in like urban policy you
know uh housing policy yinbi nimbi stuff
that kind of thing and we got to talking
that it i do feel like i especially
thought about this about some with some
of the recent debates about crime in the
united states
where the left is at such a rhetorical
disadvantage because if we want to as we
were talking about earlier historicize
and situate something and say actually
no no like this discrete problem you see
right now crime you know however
putting aside debates about how much
crime has actually increased and so on
uh let's just say crime is a problem
and you know uh you know i think the
left's answer to that or the way many of
us in left would think about it is to
say well like well what's contributing
to that crime and
you know like what social forces and
factors you know uh create kind of this
these expendable you know surplus labor
or something however you want to
describe it right people who don't fit
in then and you know what do we do them
we either put them in mental
institutions or jails kind of right and
you know it's about finding the deeper
causes and systematic
reasons why a particular issue like
crime might be surging in this moment um
whereas the wright's just like we gotta
whack him you know it's like whackable
like you know crime boom cops police
money for that please lock more people
up longer sentences harsher penalties
right and and that's a that's a easy to
grasp
answer and so i'm not really saying the
left needs to
you know uh abandon
the analyses that i think are right like
i'm saying that someone who that is how
i would think about crime you know but
uh it puts you at a real political and
rhetorical disadvantage when the more
kind of complicated and complex
uh ways you situate uh a contemporary
issue both historically and kind of uh
its place in the broader political and
social system right uh and i and so
uh
maybe that's a bit of a weasel answer
because it's saying well like you know
uh
well i don't really feel qualified you
know to to fully answer some of the
issues you raised but i do feel very
comfortable saying that's something i've
been thinking a lot about that you know
if you want to attend to complexity and
systematic factors and not just say
you know people are bad
uh or you know uh the only thing we can
do is just i mean i remember when we had
ross statham on new year enemy
it's a line that just haunted me because
it's
in a bad way um but he described like
putting the tourniquet on
uh like wrapping a tourniquet around
american society in the crime
wave of the 70s or whatever you know
like longer sentences more people in
jail he described that solutions like a
tourniquet and which is such a violent
like
disturbing image in some ways but it's
but i think it gets at
uh you know something like crime happens
the conservatives will tell you just
what to do and it won't be very
complicated and it intuitively makes
sense well shouldn't we arrest in jail
criminals
right like yeah no totally um
yeah yeah well one thing i noticed about
like the left-wing discourse is like it
ends up getting like i think about my
own students um
you know when we talk about some of
these issues
you know they've had to this summer they
had to write some argumentative essays
about like you know what what should
social movements focus on you know and
and with different problems whether it's
like you know indigenous issues in
canada or you know or the anti-racist
movement
and you know and so i think your point
about sort of like that the right has
this rhetorical advantage because they
can they can you know make these uh like
kind of simple answers and i think
what's happening a little bit that i
worry about on the left is
what starts off as a very like
complicated right like a systematic
explanation which is you know which i
think i agree with that analysis as well
but then we're seeing it get kind of
like deployed at the everyday level it's
just like oh talking about these these
what seem to a lot of people is these
vague terms as like systematic racism or
like you know and like that becomes like
a boogie word now it's like it's like
you know the right and you know working
class you know middle america sees it as
like a dog whistle for some kind of like
nefarious critical race marxism stuff
and
you know and that's just you know as
much as like i hate the like focusing
too much on the cultural war issues i
guess i do really see it as like a
little bit of a problem like the way
that that rhetoric is being used and it
just it feels like it's just giving such
fuel
uh to the right to be able to continue
to add
you know gasoline onto the the the
narrative of decline right because i
feel like all these things feed in look
at how they're just gonna they're
reducing you to racist so i guess how do
you see it like that as related yeah
just to follow that up also i want to
say that like um we were having a little
bit of discussion about how do you reach
out for instance to people um
in religious communities uh who
might be interested in adopting certain
left-wing views particularly on economic
issues uh but nevertheless
see
certain forms of let's say left-wing
secularism or materialism is just you
know a no-go you know absolutely uh and
my kind of position was that
michael waltzer you know one of the
founders of descent magazine was right i
think in a lot of context which is that
the most effective way to reach people
is what he called imminent critique
which is just a fancy way of saying if
you're trying to convince someone to
adopt an entirely different world view
than the one that they already have uh
so that you can get them to shift
politically you're probably gonna have a
really [ __ ] hard time with it right
uh because you have to start from first
principles they have to be open to that
kind of change
not going to get much very far if you
can sit there and talk to a religious
person and say well let's look at the
bible right you know what does jesus say
it says blessed are the poor blessed are
the meek do you really think that
republican politics cares that much
about poor people when you have people
like jd vance
cutting funding uh to
mothers who need uh what is the respect
formula right
right
you know and i do think that there is
something to this imminent argument
right that maybe the best thing to do is
try to reach out to people using a
language that they're familiar with and
get them to budge on the issues that
they're open to budget gone and leave
the rest aside for a little while i mean
this isn't a full kind of strategy yeah
yeah just something i've been thinking a
little bit about recently yeah no it's
um uh i'm really with you on that matt
and right after
not long after the 2016 election early
in 2017 i think descent spring issue
that year i wrote a piece on the
religious left a christian left and what
it could bring to like the broader left
project and one of the things i really
uh you know because i am religious
myself it's not just like using
religious rhetoric i have to believe it
but i do think it can
being attentive to religious communities
is a way out of this conundrum in some
ways because i think there is a
vocabulary of justice and liberation
within religious traditions that is not
that is not like an alienating or just
new and different for some people uh
more academic derived discourse
and i i was thinking about this once my
i mentioned i think that gene bethka
elshtein
who died in 2013 she was a very
well-known political theorist and public
intellectual
uh and i was i spent a lot of time with
her in some of her last years teaching i
was her ta and she taught a class on
uh
it's called the idea of freedom in
america
and um i remember one this always stayed
with me she once said
and i mentioned this in my descent
article but she once said
you know dr king didn't said he have a
he has a preference
he said he has a dream right and like
that's just like a very different
register of moral
uh capaciousness and i think
possibly of connecting with people to
use a language of like dreaming right uh
and i and i think it's no accident that
you know some of the if you look at the
high points of american
political rhetoric from the perspective
of you know someone say my politics you
look at say lincoln's second inaugural
right how drenched in
quasi-theological language that is
theological language and then someone
like dr king he was a actual minister
you know an ordained minister
uh and and
it's it just isn't surprising to me that
people
able to
use some of those terminology and
language were better able to connect
made you know that their rhetoric seems
more powerful and accessible in a way
than than some of what we see now maybe
or even fdr right uh i mean
we can all grab that fdr had big
problems and so did the new deal and
that was racially problematic in some
respects but you know you don't sit
there and remember you know the
specifics of this program or that
program you remember i'm talking about
freedom from one freedom from anxiety
all these kinds of things or freedom of
fear right these kind of very powerful
moral ideals that are put forward as
aspirations for the country to try to
achieve that's what really mobilized
people on behalf of this program i think
at least
yeah and
if you used a more opaque language or
more cynical language i don't think you
would have found people invest
themselves in the same way
yeah i kind of two two things to add to
this one is um
just about fdr i think it is forgotten
just how christian he was in a lot of
ways and i was very surprised uh
maybe last over a year ago now i had a
conversation with the historian eric
rauschway who wrote the great book
with yale university press why the new
deal matters one of those short like 200
page why x matters books but i think it
was either in the book or in the
conversation we had about it he
mentioned that there was actually a kind
of a liberal progressive christian group
that put out um
uh fdr's maybe his first inaugural but
like as an annotation of the sermon of
the mount like they were trying to
connect up the sermon on the mount and
uh and then jesus from jesus in the new
testament with
like fdr's rhetoric uh
coming into office and i was like i did
not know that and it's really
fascinating
uh and
you know uh i i would say to to be kind
of um
well both to show my kellers as a bernie
sanders fan and but also to say it's i'm
not trying to do something narrowly
religious here i do think there's a kind
of populist register too that is can be
similar i think bernie's pretty good at
it um not good enough apparently but
yeah
you know uh but like you know fight for
someone who doesn't look like you
um isn't that different than love your
neighbor as yourself
kind of you know uh and but i think
you know a an angry populist rhetoric
can be
you know sometimes the language of sin
and the language of greed aren't that
different
or you know what i mean um there's i
think there are i'm not trying to just
say all democrats are all left-wing
politicians need to start talking about
religion because i i do think it doesn't
really work if it's not sincere at some
level
uh but i i that's just say my own
thinking i really thought a lot about
the the religious uh
resources
that that you know inform my own view of
of things my own left-wing politics and
that i think when i look out at the
united states it was just you know the
fourth of july we just celebrated and i
was thinking about richard rorty's line
at the beginning of achieving our
country you know that is just as
yeah self-respect is necessary for like
individual self-improvement so a sort of
national pride is
necessary for you know
uh
the great reform movements the national
improvement improving the country you
live in uh and you know that's very
debatable even the slippage between
like national pride and individual
self-esteem or something is debatable
but i do think
you know i'm i tend to be pretty
favorable and and drawn toward
uh
uh impulses to root more of
the left-wing project in like a
distinctly american idiom uh you know
drawing on the the heroes that the left
lincoln was brilliant at that right yeah
yeah exactly you know like to the extent
uh i don't know who the the left-wing
pantheon of of heroes and heroines would
be you know in american history but you
know the left should have a usable past
the right certainly does both about
their own movement and about the
country's origins and how those two
things connect so that's i mean one way
to catch some of this out is just that
the right
they have a story they tell about
themselves which is very wiggish and you
know onward and upward um but it's
connected to
you know the american founding in the
origins of the united states uh and i
think that's something the left has a
little more problem with uh both you
know how
how we talk about what we want to
achieve now but how we situate it in
you know the american american history
both rhetorically and otherwise in terms
of the examples you point to and the
kind of you know uh the people you think
are are worth emulating in some way but
all movements need a usable past yeah i
mean i think that's really important and
i think one of the biggest problems on
the left is its tendency
you know i think it has its own
narrative of decline right which is
which which has you know um likes to
really emphasize like past wrongs um and
and kind of talk about how they're still
with us which is not untrue right um but
i think it can become uh they can become
a little bit overly fixated by it which
then ends up giving the other the other
side ammunition so i wonder i don't know
how like so i think like it's important
to be able to find a way to talk to use
uh the past for something hopeful so
yeah absolutely and i do think there's a
usable pantheon of left heroes in the
united states uh that could be
operationalized uh to inspire people
that's kind of a crude way to put it
it's very inspiring but you know you
think about lincoln and fdr maya angelou
eugene debs
mlk obviously right these are all people
who inspire me you know and i know they
inspire other people i'm not sure why it
is that sometimes we don't foreground
them as kind of a
canon of progress if you want to call it
that that's deeply rooted uh in the
american experience and i mean it would
look different elsewhere but i just want
to kind of move towards wrapping up
because uh you know we're already almost
at two hours and since you're the know
uh your enemy guy i think that we should
end on a note about conservatism uh so
what would you say are the key things
let's say the three key things that as
leftists we need to know about the
conservative movement whether we're
talking about in terms of everyday
politics it's intellectuals uh you know
it's orange demons whatever
well i was raised i was trained as an
analytical person right so there's
always got to be three of everything
it doesn't have to be three don't worry
um
well i think uh
one kind of
question before us especially uh after
the overturning of roads like just how
far will they go
and i think it's my answer is further
than you think
uh
like i'm somewhat like not a lot shocks
me on the right um and it's because
you know uh even though i mentioned that
some of the explicitly anti-liberal
anti-democratic
elements on the right we see now were
not as present 15 years ago when i was a
young person on the right
um there was still
the the kind of resentment
was it was a powerful emotion i
encountered a lot on the right and a lot
of you know um wacky ideas i mean
there's like monarchists on the right
right and it's like well so
i've seen so many of those online it's
really weird yeah i'm not saying they're
like driving republican party politics
but i'm saying if you're if you feel
comfortable being
a part of a movement that is just like
yeah people would not say yeah i'm a
monarchist
how how much are you really going to cry
over
you know some voting rights of black
people being abrogated in the south
come on right
it's just not going to be something that
flips you out uh so i think that's one
thing how far will they go further than
you think
uh
such an optimist
yeah
hard time to be an optimist yeah yeah
sure but i have to think of something
other than that um
what would you say about intellectuals
like i don't want to
i don't want us to sit here and say like
what's the core intellectual project
behind conservatism because so many
people
spent a lot of time like trying to pin
that down but what are like some of the
key things about
the right wing as an intellectual
movement that people should understand
like what is it committed to very very
broadly i think this point is worth
dwelling on though like about how far
they'll go just quit just briefly
because
i think i i worry
um
you know i think it should be a wake-up
call to like kind of the left to be able
to to actually like i'm not saying we
want to do
as you know like the the same sort of
like bad faith kind of like um politics
that that the right is doing
but god it does really make me
frustrated with like some of the kind of
like purity politics that we see on the
on the left about like oh you know we
can't vote don't vote
him because he's not left enough don't
vote for this you know like this i kind
of like hipster cynicism that i'm just
so tired of from someone on on the left
and i don't know if you have any
thoughts about that but that's one
that's that's like something i i worry
about and just like with seeing the
overturning now it just makes me so much
more mad at those people i guess the the
sort of cynical hipster leftist i
completely agree i mean i sit there and
i'm like you know there's something
really privileged about thinking that
you can focus on the narcissism of small
differences on the left uh when
the barbarians are marching and rome's
going to burn really really soon uh if
we don't all do something
yeah i mean i was someone who
you know um
was all in for bernie during the
primaries but you know when it came time
in the lead up the general election i
was really unambivalent about voting for
biden not because he hasn't disappointed
me yes not because i loved him i did but
it was just
you know uh for right now these are this
is the choice in front of us and it
would be such a catastrophe if trump won
again
uh uh
i mean the right they're really
emboldened right now um i think you know
after row the wind is at their backs uh
you know i think biden's really i mean
my goodness look at his opinion
uh you know public opinion of him the
way he's polling
uh
you know
uh things get really ugly again really
quickly uh
uh so you know i i do think
the fact that i understand the right
wing threat a certain way has made me
less inclined to at the end of the day
put up a big show of not voting for
biden or something because it's like i
guess i just don't think morally it's
that fraud of a decision because i
realize that i am privileged i live in
new york city it took me 15 minutes to
vote or 20 minutes to vote or something
right
and i know lots of people just stay in
line longer than that and that's
terrible and unfair and i
in my world i want to live and that
wouldn't happen but you know to me it
just was not a difficult decision at all
to walk over 15 or 20 minutes to the
public school gymnasium in my
neighborhood and
cast a vote for biden
um
because again it's it's you know well
even right now i mean as terrible as
biden seems to be performing and it's
pathetic and pitiful the response to the
overturning of roe like
to me it was worth it just for biden's
uh national labor relations board
if he did nothing else it was worth the
15 minutes of my time
to get you know just to uh i think be
able to support some of the the labor
victories we're seeing and union
organizing right not having a hostile
federal government in a certain kind of
way has been important and that to me
was worth the 15 minutes even if i'm
otherwise you know very disappointed in
how things have been and it's been going
it's crazy to think that you know i
think you talked about it actually on
your the part three of your of the row
episode
the fact that all these religious
conservatives could you know get on
board with trump right and it's like and
then you see on on the left that these
you know what i'm calling cynical
hipsters are like having a hard time you
know voting for biden and it's like
that's like but they're fine like these
so nominally religious people are like
yeah we'll use trump like we know he
doesn't believe in this stuff we know
he's probably paid for numerous
abortions but like he's gonna get us
what we want and you have this really
you know you pointed out some of the
kind of really amusing
i mean it's darkly amusing intellectual
loop-de-loops that people go through to
justify this i mean one of the ones that
i enjoyed you talking about was the
cyrus justification right yeah king
cyrus in the old testament yeah in the
old testament you know there's this
argument uh that king cyrus even though
he himself is not a believer or a man of
god is being used by god to advance
god's intention and a lot of right-wing
evangelicals and religious leaders would
say oh see you know it's very similar
right he might not be holy but god is
using him as an instrument and
everything that's why we need to double
down on him right now but i do just want
to come back to that one last question
just to kind of end on because i always
like to have a kind of big picture
panoramic
sweeping kind of finish so can you tell
us a little bit about like what are the
key things that conservatives want let's
just make it really brutal and to the
point like that like sure if they could
live in their ideal world
what would it look like
well um
[Music]
i'll try to answer that and i might not
be able to say their ideal world but i
think the world they're bringing into
being
um because they might not be able to get
everything they want because there is a
sense that
it's not an accident that the supreme
court has delivered the biggest
conservative win of the past however
many decades right the the branch of
government at least
um um uh
you know uh uh connected to popular
pressure the will the voters etc no not
really connected at all in some ways
right uh it's not shocking to me that
that's been done and i'm not sure
they'll be able to get everything they
want but instead
um this is what i'm seeing uh and i'm
working on it you know to go back to
mick jagger yeah yeah um you know i
think if you put together things like
the supreme court ruling about uh uh
concealed carry permits right basically
eliminating all
limitations you know on who
and where they can carry pack heat you
know out in society things like the
bounty hunter abortion law in texas
um
uh stand your ground laws
um laws that basically let people um run
over protesters in their car vehicle at
protests in marches
um the place of cops in our society both
the kind of like wildcat strikes where
they're just seeming to not deal with
you know the the story of the san
francisco dhsabudin who actually had to
rent a u-haul to bring in some
shoplifters because the cops were not
responding to him you know uh
and as they you know uh seem to
continue to kill gun people down with
near immunity
um
i i
there's something deeply anti-social at
the heart of
the right right now that you add all
these things together and it's just like
a society where being in public
um being together in public uh you know
um
thinking there are public things like
even the attacks on public schools right
like things that are held in common uh
they might not be able to overturn all
that like positively with their own
alternatives that are affirmed by
legislation into law but they can
essentially destroy
you know a sense of public things in the
common good in the united states that we
live i mean
we live in a society
um right we but but you know as margaret
thatcher told us we don't actually um uh
and you know it's it's one way of
getting their way because it throws us
back on
the private hierarchies and enforce and
you know without the state being what
equalizes citizens who otherwise might
have very different amounts of money and
power and standing in society you you
get rid of the public goods you get rid
of the sense of you know uh equality
before the law like people
you know
that sense of just basic fairness and
again public things we live in a society
uh we're basically gonna moving to a
point where we're gonna live in a in a
country where people are roaming around
with guns everywhere
um public schools are are viciously
attacked
um you know whether it's via cutting
their funding or like the groomer stuff
right so as they're giving people more
and more guns they're also saying hey
there's a bunch of pervert gays out
there trying to corrupt your kids
you know and as they're insisting that
you have to give birth whether you like
to or it or not yes slash social
programs that are there to help young
mothers yeah i mean and and
i mean it's deeply antisocial for a
woman or a pregnant person to not be
able to talk to their doctor
about a life-threatening situation like
an ectopic presidency or or pregnancy or
like a
you know miscarriage of some kind when
women are fearful and pregnant people
are fearful of walking into their doctor
because they're having a miscarriage
because they could be prosecuted for an
abortion
uh
this is just a you know i mean when you
can't talk to your doctor that way like
what kind of society are we building and
so i see
the thread that's running through so
much that's happening right now is a
kind of assault on a a democratic public
oriented um
you know we live in a society there is
such a thing as the common good we do
owe each other things and we can build
things that enhance you know our
relationships to each other and the
sense of solidarity we have and what i
see now is that you know it's there
we're kind of sliding back this is a
political theory podcast you know it's
like they're they're actually go they
think the state of nature is the good
part
right
like you know uh
that's
kind of why i see it and it makes it
very hard then for people those of us on
the left to convince people to to have
hope for more solitaristic democratic
um
ways of of living together right it's
just you hunker down you say i have mine
i just want to keep it that's all i can
hope for i can just keep my [ __ ] and
have my guns and fend off people who
want to take it from me and that's
that's the extent of your political and
social horizon that's what i really fear
uh
and
you know i s when you really start
adding up the gun stuff the abortion
stuff
the attacks on public schools
so on and so forth you do really see
this i think deeply anti-social
atomized like you know people shouldn't
trust each other
uh every fight you get into at a public
place could turn and you could be mowed
down you could be mowed down in your
place of worship you know yeah um
so that's
uh
it's a very pessimistic note to end on
but it's what i see happening and i
think but i especially wanted to mention
it because i think for me as someone on
the left i think about it a lot like uh
we we don't just have to win and like
achieve things straightforwardly that we
all know we have to do it's part of the
task is i think overcoming
what's becoming a more deeply ingrained
kind of sociopathic um
you know uh low trust
uh society where people are gonna be on
edge and and uh
you know the prospect of collective
action
uh ordered toward the common good
you know enacted democratically is just
becoming something i think is harder and
harder for people to really imagine in a
robust way
yeah i got to say uh john kennedy
galbraith once said that the modern
conservatives engaged in one of man's
oldest intellectual enterprises uh which
is to figure out a superior moral
justification for selfishness uh and
that might not be entirely true or
entirely fair but it definitely
expresses something really important and
on that chilling note uh and on your
dystopian vision of the future i just
want to say that it was a real pleasure
for you to come on uh i love this
conversation i wish we could carry on
for another half hour but it would be
too much um so thank you so much and
thank you for teaching both of us uh a
lot about what's going on in american
conservatives no problem it was my
pleasure i had a lot of fun we could
have kept going i'm only just now
getting really wound up as you can tell
by my last answer so uh thank you very
much i appreciate it
thanks
all right
awesome
[Music]